[Music]
in cats to do news submitted by iPhone Z
a man rented a $1500 studio apartment
just for his cats that's cute but he was
even living there
no I don't want to not live there yeah
what's the point of having pets for now
I'll be with the pets it's like having
an ant farm
[Laughter]
look at them yeah that's really true
probably has a camera and they're
looking at it or like a hamster yeah ant
farms are fun as [ __ ] okay
but you wear the hamster in the ball and
then it's like all over those oh yeah
when that [ __ ] leaks out of little holes
and shits flying everywhere you ever
start started that ant farm business is
a genius that's like the pet rock yeah
it's so funny like you it's like I'm
gonna sell rocks to people to you watch
me well at least with the ants you can
see science like you can see how animals
interact in their own habitat so funny
though it was a raucous is psyched
you're buying a bunch of dirt and you
get ants or the one that um but you
could buy this for the person that has
everything and it's just the ball with
like nothing in it it's like the
emperor's new clothes thing right that's
like that app remember the app that was
ten thousand dollars and it was just
like a portable app and it just has a
purple actually paid for that people
just wanted it on their screen they
wanted it as a status symbol so they
could be like I was able to just throw
away ten thousand dollars just like that
you know but that's like the people who
it's like people twitch streamers
getting like 25 G's out of nowhere it's
the same [ __ ] what you do
I don't know ant I'm on it freestyle I
should all you have to do is like walk
towards the camera
eat something walk away from the camera
walk back towards I drop something you
walk away walk away from the camera
and then people don't know if you're
coming back or not and that's the whole
mystery no just keep watching just see
minutes of wait for you come back where
a boob shirt where a boob shirt easy for
you easy easy for me easy for you you
have many boob shirts right so then you
sit there with a controller you don't
even have to have a game and you have
the headset I need
there and you just make like and just
make cooking sounds with it and be like
oh hey yeah look and I like this game's
omelet right you could just put on
another gamers like [ __ ] like there's
a bunch of buttons that's pretty good
and then someone will catch you they'll
be like oh I saw like I played in that
game and then I'll be a scandal so your
channel blow yeah I'm in I'm in when can
we start I guess that's what I get a cut
yeah yeah you think you see I I love the
process alright so this man his name is
um well fossa actually I don't have his
name the ret the what oh I do actually
I'm sorry let me start over this man
named Torre he's worried I would have
never guessed that yeah me neither
oh my god his name's not Tony
[Music]
I won't guess that one either
alright so anyway I guess boy he's 43
years old yeah don't laugh a dyslexic
person that was a letter country I
suffer from this since I was a kid a
letter train I write dyslexic sometimes
like I'll write words all jumbled by
accident all the time what I'm texting
my peas on my B's like [ __ ] I always
write the letter ahead of the letter I
want always you guys have a review guys
receive texts for me they're all [ __ ]
not
you guys are so d I never never get
texted from yugioh autocorrect who'll it
always [ __ ] me up too sometimes nope I
can't blame it anyway so Troy he has a
daughter who recently went to school she
went off to school and he moved into a
new apartment with his fiancee and her
dog and so now that his daughter is gone
there's nowhere to put his her two cats
so the only other solution that they
come up with is his friend was renting
out this $1,500 a month studio apart
behind his home and so he was like hey I
have nowhere else to put these cats I
can't get rid of them because if beloved
to the family and to my daughter they
can't fit in our apartment and then they
fight with the dog so and then the
daughter can't take the cats because she
lives in a dorm room so that they just
came up with a solution that's how he
gets away from his girlfriend
it's his like MANPADS like I got a check
on the cat yeah you'll in a couple hours
it's so funny but yeah I mean they the
guy that's renting it he's like well
they're pretty easy tenants they do
stink up the place but they don't oh no
I don't do anything else do they should
just get the robot kitty litter cleaner
it's like you'll have to change it every
thirty days and it's like yeah I know me
too it's just you don't make pretty ones
like ours right now look like planters
so no one can ever tell where the litter
boxes are and they're covered so it it
erases a lot of the scent
yeah I didn't see any litter boxes their
place because their plans you call them
yeah we smell them sometime sure today
man as I was leaving I was like I
[ __ ] tasty I know I know but I was on
my way out the door do you guys smell
ours no I don't even know you have cats
I swear to god you catch alike so why do
me like leave such a low print footprint
oh oh man just if you would live with
them though there's one cat he likes to
poop in places you show me poop Oh our
bed or in the bathroom floor and it's
like dude the kitty litter is literally
right in front of where you literally
literally hear a dirty he's like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] he's so bougie but then we'll
change everything out and then he'll
still poop on the floor so now we're
thinking we have to change the actual
plastic it's going to make you feel me
one of our cats sometimes pees on Nikki
yeah windows not satisfied we can't make
you feel better than you were
I thought I could but you already top
that my story will never be told wait I
want to hear what's gonna make her feel
better
you kid did he busy barf on you and do
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] cuz you like
[ __ ] in your new be buffed once actually
yeah and that's our fault because we
were driving through a big bear it's a
lot of windy roads I was gonna try to
make you feel better but before he said
his since it's been raining bougie-ass
[ __ ] hundred pound German Shepherd
meat and [ __ ] loaf is a little
[ __ ]
he doesn't want to go outside from his
[ __ ] special made doggy door that we
have for him because his paws are gonna
get wet in the [ __ ] breed so he can't
poop outside so this [ __ ] holds
it oh he starts running in circles
oh yeah take him out with a little
umbrella okay give a little rainbow well
I didn't know this opponent Hopkins when
he actually does go outside tells the
whole time yes this little alleyway
right where it on the side watch the
truck is high ground like this like this
typically on the side where the water it
goes down look at the tire growth that
is a bougie Tom walks around the house
and then if you're not paying attention
to him moving around like frantically
because we're watching a child then he
goes and he shits in the kitchen oh my
god because dog poo is like juicy yeah
yeah cuz I gave them raw meat to clear
out their stomach so like once a month I
try to do that so it was [ __ ] loose
and he likes that [ __ ] and walk so be
shitty what are you gonna pee pad for
this the just the rainy days you want to
use too okay
he's your kid you gotta [ __ ] be
hard-on
I can't can't wait to go outside of the
rain he begs and begs and begs and he
gets out there and he just feels the
rain like blinks into it I tell this
story to my [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] mail by the way well tell her
we'll talk about your dog story to [ __ ]
my mom does egg talks to the [ __ ]
animals like that oh you wouldn't
believe what happened yesterday she's so
lonely yeah I should call her more thank
you but I won't all right here's some
photos of where these cats live so this
is in Silicon Valley that's a nice house
people are like wow this is reached peak
Silicon Valley status cuz these two
can't like you know there's like a
housing crisis there where there's a lot
of homeless people is just so expensive
to marry cap teen hundred dollars a
month but I just want um the cats are
like we have a pool what we barely use
it yes of the guy that's raining at this
place he was like well you know this
unit doesn't have a kitchen so we didn't
really want to put on Airbnb or cuz they
were considering that but [ __ ] is it a
garage that they converted and today it
is hmm cuz it's such a weird studio it's
nice to look at the TV kitchenette yeah
yeah I know like why do they need a
house furniture it's a bachelor pad for
the guy to get away from oh you see are
you saying they shouldn't get Christmas
presents hi
well they got the TV in the soundbar for
Christmas and we got a wall Mountain
yeah I thought the guy that owns it
that's like his [ __ ] yeah it's probably
already there's a mini-fridge in there
to see the guy goes there he chills it's
a good plan that is such a good idea
yeah
you got a xbox over there I feel like I
need to start looking for
good enough just separate studios that's
funny yeah but I don't know they were
just now everyone is talking about this
it's like how do these cats live there
you know when they show you like those
Netflix shows that like to show you
these crazy like [ __ ] awesome houses
that people have there was this one guy
that had cats I think he had like four
cats called extraordinary home oh yeah
um and this guy had like two being all
over the house you saw that oh yeah yeah
we saw that mm-hmm wasn't it bad at 26
cats or something like that
I'd like the litter box 26 but the
litter boxes were out in like this patio
it was like half outside half inside
patio and there were like fans and stuff
so it never smells and his place looked
really good yeah it holes so that the
cats could have shortcuts to write you
didn't want the cat stuff to go the long
way so there's like you can go straight
from this bedroom to the living room
I love when he's being interviewed
because he's like he's like people think
I'm crazy but just that one room where
they're like that was the first ramp I
think I would want to make it and then
see my [ __ ] creation like action be
yeah yeah was this a gay couple no I
think the guy by himself
I saw one why was a gay couple is a gay
couple yeah two different stories here
but ya know we saw the house looked
amazing and like Mediterranean style yes
maybe I don't know but yeah and then
they were saying like you never even
noticed the cats because they're just
always
we saw I think we all saw the same one
yeah how weird fucked-up memories yeah
with another episode or something yeah
yeah I think I think yeah but yeah we
definitely you think we've seen it or
not yeah yeah exactly
[Music]
[Music]